drugs they're the third most annoying
thing in the sky after mosquitoes and
plastic bags caught in the breeze they
are not gorgeous weird kid from American
Beauty they're trash and they kill sea
turtles
you've got turtle blood on your hands
but all of a sudden drugs are everywhere
we even use them to shoot romantic
wedding videos and what could possibly
go wrong with that I don't know if this
fight it's funny whether it's fine or
not but look overseas drones are a
slightly more serious matter for
instance this week we reportedly
launched deadly drone strikes in both
Waziristan and Yemen you probably didn't
hear about them on the news unless you
were watching this the u.s. has carried
out another drone attack in Pakistan's
restive tribal areas killing at least
eight people that's the only footage
reporting either strike that we could
find and it's from the Iranian
government's english-language TV station
that channel is buried deep in your
cable package I think it's actually
somewhere between c-span jr. and can the
Kirstie Alley Network but there is there
is something strange about the fact that
we launched two deadly drone strikes in
two sovereign nations that almost no one
here heard about but then again why
would it make the news we use drones all
the time hard numbers are very difficult
to come by for reasons that we'll get
into but by one estimate during the
Obama administration we've launched
eight times the number of John strikes
than we did under his predecessor and
while they've declined a bit recently
drone strikes will be as much a
characteristic of the Obama presidency
as a bomber care or receiving racist
email for words from distant relatives
and it's easy to see why drones are so
popular they cost less than manned
planes and they kill a lot of terrorists
their slogan should really be
appealingly cheap and incredibly deadly
but unfortunately that's already been
taken by Hardee's
and and and they're not just popular
with the white house surveys
consistently show a majority of
Americans approve of our use of drone
strikes to fight extremists abroad in
fact we're so comfortable with them
nobody blinked an eye when the president
said this the Jonas Brothers are here
they're out there somewhere
sasha and malia are huge fans but boys
don't get any ideas I have two words for
you
Predator drones you will never see it
coming you'll either your eye or tis
riddled with shrapnel fired from the sky
gurgling your last blood-soaked breath
it's it's funny cuz it's possible I
could do that that's something I could
do but while our drone program is widely
accepted we really know relatively
little about it we spent a lot of time
this week trying to find some concrete
answers to basic questions and it's
surprisingly difficult for instance how
do we decide when to use a drum strike
now on the surface the Obama
administration's answer seems
straightforward we only take these kinds
of actions when there's an imminent
threat when capture is not feasible and
when we are confident that we're doing
so in a way that's consistent with
federal and international law okay that
sounds reassuring until you look closer
at it because our rules for drone
strikes a little like Harvey Keitel's
balls we've all seen them in the piano
Bad Lieutenant or on snapchat and from a
distance you think oh I understand the
contours of those but if you were to
really examine them you discover that
they're actually lost in a haze of
fuzziness and gray areas much like the
rules for our drone strikes as Eric
Holder just said drone strikes are
justified if you can show an imminent
threat now that sounds clear there's not
much of a linguistic loophole there
unless you make one NBC News has
obtained this confidential 16 page
Justice Department memo it says an
imminent threat does not require the
United States to have clear evidence
that a specific attack on US
persons and interests will take place in
the immediate future what an imminent
threat does have to take place in the
immediate future
because that's what the word imminent
means when someone says I'm going to
have a baby imminently it doesn't mean I
may or may not have a baby at some point
in the future it means get your
car keys my water just broke and it
turns out imminent isn't the only word
with a surprisingly fluid definition
when it comes to drone strikes what
defines a civilian when it comes to
civilian casualties has also allegedly
been open to interpretation there's also
been some dispute over the way civilian
casualties are counted the CIA often
counts able-bodied males military age
males who are killed in strikes as
militants unless they have concrete
evidence to to sort of prove them
innocent hold on if it's assumed you're
with the terrorists if you're in the
same vicinity and around the same age as
them then by that standard as a British
man in my 30s whenever I go home to
London I'm a member of Coldplay and
that's offensive to me that's offensive
I'm not being in that band for years we
consciously uncoupled a long time ago
perhaps the most incredible thing about
our drone program which again a majority
of us support is not how little we know
about who the government is killing but
how little they themselves seem to know
NBC News has examined classified
documents detailing 114 drone strikes
they also reveal what US officials don't
know like how many killed between seven
and ten in one strike 22 22 in another
it suggests US officials don't always
know exactly how many or who they're
killing that is a little disturbing
because the question how many people
have you killed in drone strikes it's
not one of those questions where it's
okay to say I don't know it's not like
asking someone who was the voice of
Disney's Aladdin or what are skittles
made from it's different it's different
than that and the crazy thing is it
literally always been like this the very
first CIA drone strike back in 2002
killed three men reportedly because they
thought one of them might have been bin
Laden in part and this is true due to
his height and under that rationale it's
kind of remarkable that we didn't take
out Jeff Goldblum at some point over the
years now reports later indicated the
victim was actually an innocent man who
was collecting scrap metal and look how
the Pentagon immediately set the
template for every discussion we've had
about drone strikes since you said you
don't know who is killed in this attack
whether it's civilians Hotel Boehner I'm
sorry exactly we don't know the
identities of the individuals involved
but you're convinced they're Taliban
we're convinced yep we're convinced it
was an appropriate target based on the
observation based on the information
that it was an appropriate target we do
not know yet exactly who it was it's
never a good idea to make a major
decision about someone when you can't
even say exactly who they are hey guys
I got married last night oh really who
is he I don't know exactly at this time
but unconvinced he's an appropriate
husband based on his height and yet
we've consistently let the government
get away with answers like that because
drone strikes are one of those things
that it's really convenient not to think
about that much like the daily life of a
circus elephant or the fact that Beck is
a Scientologist
you will you only don't want people
reminding you about those kind of things
but if you happen to live underneath
drums not thinking about them is not an
option having drones hovering above you
is bound to mess with your head
especially because you might not even be
able to see them even though I know
there's a predator directly overhead I
still can't hear a thing and if you look
up to the exact spot where we're being
told the predator is flying right now
there's nothing but clouds and blue sky
congratulations everyone we did it we
managed to make one of the last
remaining Universal symbols of
pleasantness blue sky completely
terrifying we
but while we may not spend much time
thinking about our drone strikes here
in countries like Pakistan where they
actually happen they have to deal with
them so much there there are even weird
satirical cartoons featuring an American
drone and his friend a dengue fever
carrying mosquito Italian but the would
be a bedazzler Pakistan yes I like that
yeah I like that
Danny yeah I'm gonna borrow your head do
ya get more diplomatic alive which gear
Gandia maybe please Allah say a hero
easily it on Pakistan me Marty Gary hey
to be fair that would be a lot funnier
if you spoke Urdu and lived in constant
fear of being murdered by a drone if you
did that's basically who's on first
in fact drone strikes are such a routine
feature of life in Pakistan this is how
news networks present statistics about
them Pakistani who kumejima this
ecologic Jalopnik palace visitor partner
is right at the fatiha Orca hockey
America
drones have their own graphics package
you do not invest in quality graphics
like those unless you know you're gonna
get a lot of use out of them
it's like Las Vegas local news having
white tiger mauling graphics they're
going to get their money's worth but to
really understand the psychological
impact of living underneath drugs listen
to this Yemeni man a man who loves
America
addressing Congress last year only a
week after his village was struck by a
drone I spent there living with an
American family and I attended an
American high school that was one of the
best years of my life the friendships
and values I experienced and described
to the villagers helped them understand
the America that I know and that I love
now however but when they think of
America
they think of the terror they feel from
the drones that hover over their heads
ready to fire missiles any time the
drone strikes at the face of America too
many Yemenis and that kind of makes
sense because think about it this way if
there were Italian armed drones hanging
over your head right now it would
probably affect the way you
think about Italy in word-association
your first answer for Italy would not be
lasagna it would be specter of imminent
death or more likely expect over the
imminent death followed by lasagna if
you grow up underneath drums it's going
to affect the way you see the world
listen to this thirteen-year-old
Pakistani boy whose grandmother was
killed in a drone strike I tell me he
left that I no longer loved blue skies
in fact I now prefer gray skies the
drones do not fly when the skies are
gray and for a short period of time the
mental tension and fear eases look it is
completely natural for us not to want to
think about the consequences of our
drone program but when children from
other countries are telling us that
we've made them fear the sky it might be
time to ask some hard questions the
problem is after a week of looking at
this it seems there are shockingly few
available answers in fact the best
summation we could find of the framework
we use to authorize and justify drone
strikes is from this former defense
department advisor right now we have the
executive branch making a claim that it
has the right to kill anyone anywhere on
earth at any time for secret reasons
based on secret evidence in a secret
process undertaken by unidentified
officials that frightens me yeah it
probably does frighten you because what
you just described sounds
terrifying and look any counterterrorism
effort will always require an element of
secrecy but with our drug program not
only do we not know who we've killed the
legal guidelines have loopholes large
enough to drive a flying death robot
through and after a week spent trying to
comprehend the rationales legality and
broader consequences of our drug policy
I'm starting to understand how this guy
feels
exactly
[Applause]